but Jesus saved us anywhere is there any
word which Jesus says that we can plow
our wives is there anywhere where Jesus
says that we can beat our wives no look
and see what Jesus says Ephesians
chapter 5 verse 25 husbands are to love
their wives as Christ loved the church
we believe the time and as Christ was
willing to die for the church so a
husband should be willing to die for his
wife
ooh I love Jesus what a contrast we have
between Jesus and Mohammed we're going
to go and do some more comparisons where
does it say in the New Testament that a
woman has half the testimony in court
look at the greatest event in the whole
history of mankind the resurrection of
Jesus from the dead who did Jesus show
himself to Jesus showed himself to a
woman now to the disciples don't you a
man but to a woman knowing that in first
century Judaism the testimony of a woman
is half of that of a man yet Jesus chose
a woman female it see where Muhammad
chooses a woman to be a testimony for
him let's see for Muhammad the nobles
women as I hear Muslims tell me all the
time let's do a comparison tonight and
this asked is really Jesus the model for
today or is Muhammad the model today I
now give it to Ali to convince us the
Muhammad is that model am I finished
right now bye guys now this copybooks
wide if I'm gonna go
okay now he talks about the Braun says
be your wife are you know know where
woman's right money like that
you look at a Bible do you enemy chapter
25 verse 11
he's talking about the fraud apparently
says you don't be a wife so yeah
the Bible says if me and Jay are
fighting my wife is involved I shook her
hand off Ryan are you guys handle for
helping you Oh what kind of hypnotized
Word of God that you you my wife is
coming to bat Fiat and I'm like you know
what I'm gonna call you handle
ridiculous let's talk about Mohammed we
are gonna shame we are brows on an hour
later so what did the Prophet Muhammad
peace be up in upstate when how many
Muslims I up we all so what did the
Prophet Muhammad say where is heaven on
the way your mother's be your line your
mother to be others feet yeah this is
how we honor the woman instead
he said to the people the ones the best
amongst you are the world bow best to
your wife the ones dog best among you
are the ones our best to your wife but
he doesn't want to know but we're
talking about mine
the so honorable so respectful he has a
neighbor every time he leaves his house
if a neighbor flows babish on his head
he comes back painful rubbish on his
head for yet for a rubbish on his head
will he ever turn around and trusted
angry no one day when he's walking home
no rubbish and he's thinking to himself
100 his lady goes inside and she'll know
she's dying
he goes and brace for this is the
character of mohammad portable engine
revs now when it comes to work right in
Islam you know my friend Jay he's a life
you can see here so when you watch BBC
they were something in common in world
if you look into the Bible Deuteronomy
chapter 34 verse 16 hey no sorry first
of you
First Samuel if you look into it guys it
tells you go to that Malik I kill men
women children in the physics of baby
and don't jump it what do the document
what did the baby do what kind of effort
is that and this is one when you go to
work you know home trees you know over
birds the animals do not kill women you
don't kill children your Bible is
allowing women women children even
animals man maybe the doctors right
where's the animal rights where's the
children right where's the woman right I
want Muhammad peace be upon him said do
not touch a tree you believe he's going
to go a few kids your Bible clearly says
cubasis how to reverse all kind of a
loving body that is that loving você
it's not loving what we think we are
scared of talking about Mohammed we are
proud we are proud okay from chef you
notice the only brushes he can quote are
from Deuteronomy let's read Deuteronomy
I want you to read what is he think he
forgot to tell you about that first 26
in the tooth visual like men getting
into a fight and the wife of one of the
clans to risk your helmet by grabbing
the testicle yes didn't you mention that
wow the other man and you must cut off
her hands and give you the attention
that are you gonna talk about he didn't
wrench in that white because he didn't
want you to hear that part of it but
first let me ask you how many Christians
follow Deuteronomy today none do we
follow
Deuteronomy long do we follow Mosaic law
these Mosaic law it's in 1400 BC do we
go back to that long no we don't who do
we go to G not Moses not Joshua not
David to Jesus Jesus fulfills all of
that he says that in Matthew by I have
not come to destroy the law I have come
to fulfill the law and then he gives us
six different applications in Matthew
Bible as how he does that look and see
what he says you have heard it say an
eye for an eye and a tooth written but I
now say turn the other cheek
you have her to say to hate your enemies
and love your neighbors but now I say to
love your enemies that is a complete new
law takes the Old Testament law and
fulfills everything that God was doing
back then in 1400 BC we are to love our
enemies did Mohammed ever love his
enemies is there any reference about
loving your enemies in this book you all
find it that you will only find in the
gospel of Jesus Christ
that's what do we call to do today to
love those who we would normally hate
now tell me who is the better model
Jesus or Muhammad
it's Muhammad who did went on to say to
slay those look at sea and sir 95 slay
the unbelievers besiege them lay in wait
for them with every kind of ambush this
is Muhammad's revelation this is the
last surah it was revealed to your
prophet in 1632 the year he died it's
the most authoritative sort of it
say surah in verse 29 it says make war
on the people little bugs
that's the Jews and the Christians
you're to make war upon us in surah 47
ayah 4 it says cut off the heads of the
unbeliever
so how could Mohammed be a man of peace
if you want a man of peace folks you
better come back to Jesus Christ guess
it's only Jesus that talks about these
Jesus is the one that says to love your
enemies Jesus is the Lord that says to
turn the other cheek Jesus is the one
that says blessed are the peacemakers
one minute you have to give me one bit
get a fictional family go from there
make sure you give me one minute now
one minute every minute you can I change
it to 300 you have so many 4.3.3 okay
okay guys you have advice he goes he
says when he quoted he didn't say that
the woman grabbed his genitals even if
he grabbed the guy's eyes is that right
to chop her hand off no idea well hold
on a second you're saying oh he didn't
close the pay raise and grabber Jenna -
are you real
Aven grab the Genesis or wherever is
there right to come woman handle are you
serious Jane I'm gonna give me a break
man much too much horror movies
now he says a lot of Allah Muhammad
peace be upon him was about to his
enemies are you sure I mean to be the
front again this is a hadith I said by
Allah
I'm not kill my captain they go to work
with people that want to kill them they
have cut this camp this and it goes by
Allah I will lock you my capture and
none of my companies will kill is
captured when we reach the Prophet we
mentioned this boy with a message in the
whole story on that the plumbing raised
both his mother said o Allah I am free
of innocent of his will see I said
clearly is this clearly is employment we
spoke on it when he was agent he was
sharing with his captain now what Jesus
is Jesus look at you now I changed in
yet Jesus loves enemies see another
contradiction the photo with Christians
you don't know their Bible live chapter
19 verse 27
what does Jesus say bring my enemies and
slay them I don't want you used to love
me like that he could keep up himself
during my enemy home and stay there
passionate me
yes and another another let's talk about
Muhammad peace be upon our you remind
you to treat women behind me
now more ladies and gentlemen he's
saying that in Old Testament it says it
shall vanish much you hear trend on the
cheek
now the God came along and changed his
mind can you believe in a God that says
if he slaps you here give out the cheap
but now he says you know if he takes
your jacket
give him your t-shirt it is claps New
York tended to start this way it's got
changes mange come on let's be real now
this is statistics when fire or punish
in Georgia how many times is mentioned
in the Quran how many times you mention
in the Bible in the Quran 621 times in
the Bible 1,200 type fear terror
verified in the prime a hundred eighty
three hundred in the Bible over a
thousand times
anger despite the chest pain konjac
seventy four times in the Quran over two
thousand times in the Bible
and how cool
like as a whole